هذا الزمن الذي استقبله الانسان وبدا
يعيشه توجد به كثير من التحديات والتغيرات
وبسبب هذه التحديات والتغيرات بدات هنا
دول العالم تستعد بمختلف الاستراتيجيات
والخطط وتاتي في مقدمه هذه الاستراتيجيات
والخطط المتعلقه بمجال
التعليم ولا غرابه في
ذلك فصنع الانسان هنا وتحديد
مساره يتم اولا على ايدي العلماء
والمربيين فهم يصنعون المعرفه العلميه
التي يحتاج اليها زمن
المستقبل وهم ايضا يمدون الطلاب في
المدارس والمعاهد
والجامعات بالمعرفه والتقنيه العلميه
والاجتماعيه التي تساعدهم على التكيف
والعيش والاسهام في المجتمع
الجديد ولكن هناك سؤالا يطرح
نفسه اين نحن من
ذلك هل يمتلك معلمنا مهارات معلم القرن
الحادي والعشرين من اجل ان يسلح بها
طلابنا
عند تحليل واقع المعلم في وقتنا
الحاضر تؤكد الدراسات والتقارير انه لا
يزال معلما
تقليديا يمارس مهامه في اطار تقليدي لا
يتعدى نقل المعلومات وتصحيح الدفاتر ووضع
الدرجات اذا هو معلم لا يزال بعيدا عن
معلم الاعداد للمجتمع
الجديد اذا كانت المدارس والمعاهد
والجامعات ومراكز البحث العلمي هي صانعه
الالفيه
الثالثه فان
المعلم ان المعلم هو المسؤول الاول
والمعني عن كل هذه العمليات الابداعيه
لصنع المجتمع
الجديد العالم من حولنا
يتغير التطور العلمي التقدم التكنولوجي له
اثره ادراكات احتياجات توقعات الطلاب ايضا
تتغير اذا لابد ان تتغير طرق التعليم حتى
تواكب هذه التغيرات التي تحيط
بنا هناك طريقه اذا تم تبنيها من قبل
مؤسساتنا التعليميه سوف ننمي جزءا من
مهارات معلم وطالب القرن الحادي
والعشرين هذه الطريقه يطلق عليها التعليم
المقلوب من المتعارف عليه ان التعليم في
مؤسساتنا في وقتنا
الحاضر هو الدرس في البيت الدرس في الصف
والواجب في
البيت لكن طريقه التعليم المقلوب هنا تقوم
بقلب العمليه التعليميه بحيث يقوم هنا
المعلم باعداد مقطع فيديو يستخدم فيه
مجموعه من الوسائل السمعيه والبصريه
وبرامج المحاكاه والتقيييم التفاعلي
ثم بعد ذلك يعطي هذا المعلم هذا الفيديو
الى طلاب ل الاطلاع عليه في
بيوت لما ياتي هنا الطالب الى الصف يكون
على استعداد تام لتطبيق هذه المفاهيم
وايضا المشاركه في الانشطه
الصفيه وحل الواجبات داخل قاعه
الصف هذه الطريقه
تم تطبيقها في مؤسسه تعليميه في بلدنا وهي
كليه المجتمع سيئون ولقد قبول وتفاعل من
قبل طلاب الكليه والان نستعرض لكم نماذج
من الجانب العملي عن هذه
الطريقه اولا الوصف
الحسابي وهو من اهم مقايس النزعه المركزيه
واكثرها استخداما في النواحي العمليه
والتطبيقيه في
حياتنا ويمكن التطر
الى هذا المقاس من ناحيتين او في حالتين
في حاله البيانات المبوبه وفي حاله
البيانات
غيرص لموجه الموجبه لكن عمل او سمح بمرور
ال الموجه السالبه لاحظ الموجه كلها بهذا
الشكل موجه كامله هذه الموجه كامله
بالنسبه ل الموجه الداخله او الموجه من
المصدر لكن الموجه الخارجه من الداود
عباره عن قص للموجه الموجبه والسماح بمرور
الموجه السالبه لانها بتكون الدايود في
انحياز في انحياز
امان
يمكن توضيح او التمييز بين انواع المدراء
من جانبين اثنين الاول من حيث المستوى
الاداري الذي يشغله المدير في المنظمه
التي يعمل فيها والثاني من حيث القطاع
الاداري الذي يمارس المدير فيه نشاط
وقت المحاضره الاستغلال
الامثل
وايضا تراعي الفروقات الفرديه لدى الطلاب
بحيث يستطيعون الطالب على تكرار ذلك
الفيديو اكثر من مره حتى يتقبل ذلك الدرس
ويفهم
ايضا تساعد هذه الطريقه على ربط التعليم
بمجال التكنولوجيا وتربط هنا علاقه وطيده
بين المعلم وطلابه والطالب وزملائه اضافه
الى ذلك الا انه تساعد هنا الطالب على
التفكير الناقد والتعليم
الذاتي ايضا تساعدنا هذه الطريقه على حل
مشكله الفجوه القائمه بين الجانب النظري
والجانب العملي في العمليه
التعليميه ايضا تساعدنا على انشاء منصه
تعليميه يتم فيها وضع هذه الفيديوهات من
ادل يستفيد منها جميع ابناء
بلدنا هذه خطوه
بدانا بها وستستمر لنعود الى
المستقبل